as they prepare to head out to the World
Cup these are the players who'll carry
the hopes of a Nation with them if the
lionesses can go all the way it'll be
the first time England have won the
World Cup since
1966. so as the players faced the Press
there was one big question can you bring
the World Cup home
we're going to make sure we're the best
prepared we possibly can be going into
this tournament it's you know the
biggest stage in football and there's
um yeah you're playing against the
world's top team so it's definitely
going to be a challenge but like I said
all we can do is make sure we're the
best prepared and we go out there and
play our hearts out as always
it does feel that if any team can do it
they can raising the trophy as European
Champions last summer they won the
support and respect of the nation they
go into the World Cup among the
favorites having come close before but
have faced setbacks with injuries ruling
out some of the Stars Captain Leah
Williamson Beth Mead and Fran Kirby of
course we do have some great players out
of the squad but we also have some great
players in the squad and I think it
gives opportunities to others to step up
and show what they can do as well so I
think we try and focus on what we do
have here and and the depth that we have
in the squad is incredible
many of the lionesses became household
names last summer and since then the
profile of the women's game has
undoubtedly risen but they go into the
world cup with women's pay still falling
far behind men's
it's going to take a long time the fight
will keep happening we'll keep fighting
like the Pioneers before us did to to
even enable me to stand in this position
right now like England's men back in 66
the win last year was on home turf at
Wembley it's great what we did for women
women in sport last year and women's
football of course and it's about making
those memories again they'll head off to
Australia and New Zealand knowing no
England football team has ever won a
major championship abroad but these
lionesses have taught us to Dare To
Dream Becky Johnson Sky News at St
George's Park